ces alliances symbolise l'engagement
profond non métaux matchs fiche de moi
désolé c'est une question de dix morts
certes oistamo pour me sauver jean route
devait
au mont dieu sait quoi
oui j'espère ne pas arriver trop tard
non voilà qui on a deux maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe ok je vous la
fait courte
robotnik est de retour
j'ai découvert la source du pouvoir
absolu
il faut qu'on récupère les motivant
c'est la fin du monde
ce dernier une espèce de
deux porcs-épics spatiale je suis un
guerrier et kinés
lhérisson il est temps de dire au revoir
à l'humanité
d'où la nouvelle donne
c mende être un grand héros alors je
sais que je devrais pas dire ça mais en
fait je n'ai pourtant fort
et un petit point rouge sur le front au
furet on a commandé urbain qui fait
froid ici
réchauffer l'ambiance
[Musique]
bravo
génial le soldat ni vers nous
les craintes citoyen est vraiment nul
comme le héros autre attitude négative
l'indicé phare
on reste unis quoi qu'il arrive
incapable
incompétent
ati
tu as oublié une chose
je suis imbattable
[Musique]
reste tranquille et mal pour quelqu'un
qui dit avoir de la poigne t'as pas
beaucoup de patates